on va tout de suite rejoindre notre
envoyé spécial et Elena Volochine à
course que bonjour à vous Elena quelles
sont les derniers mouvements de troupe
que vous observez
alors je suis à Belgorod à moins de 30
km de la frontière avec l'Ukraine et ici
l'ambiance est radicalement différente
de celle que j'avais observé à course où
j'étais hier effectivement qui se trouve
plus loin à 130 km où les gens ne se
rendent vraiment pas compte presque pas
compte du fait que que qu'il y a un
conflit et une guerre juste à côté il
voyait passer eux des bombardiers mais
il n'y avait pas eu il n'avait pas
entendu d'explosion alors qu'ici à
Belgorod je suis donc dans les dans les
quartiers sud la frontière comme je
disais tu as moins de 30 km et hier
matin il y a eu des combats on entendait
des explosions on voyait passer des
hélicoptères des des avions et en fait
ce qui s'était passé et on le sont là su
seulement plus tard c'est que c'était le
moment où la Russie en fait a attaqué le
poste frontière pour lancer l'offensive
sur la deuxième plus grande ville
ukrainienne carquif en ce moment on a
pas exactement d'informations sur ce qui
se passe là-bas apparemment il y a des
combats pour la prise de carquif des des
éléments non confirmés hier disait que
la ville aurait été en par l'armée russe
alors ici aujourd'hui à belgorodes les
rues sont plutôt sont plutôt désertes
par rapport à d'habitude à cette
heure-ci nous disait notre chauffeur il
y a toujours des embouteillages les gens
vont ton travail alors que là on a
circulé à librement c'est vrai que
personne ne s'attendait à ce qu'il y ait
ses détonations et tout d'un coup cette
guerre juste à côté Vladimir Poutine n'a
absolument pas annoncé au préalable que
la Russie allait entrer en conflit
d'ailleurs il ne l'a toujours pas dit de
telle façon et ni confirmé il affirmer
une opération de pour amener la paix et
la démocratie en Ukraine donc les Russes
ici de ce côté-ci de la frontière ont du
mal à comprendre ce qui se passe ont du
mal à se préparer ont du mal à savoir
comment vont évoluer la situation il est
certain que apparemment d'après ce qu'on
observe la Russie elle a priorité en ce
qui concerne la force militaire et la
priorité numérique sur l'armée
ukrainienne maintenant ici de ce côté-là
évidemment les habitants redoute que
s'il s'agit d'une guerre d'artillerie il
va y avoir des dégâts Simon ou n'importe
quoi qui pourrait qui pourrait toucher
directement les les quartiers et les
habitations ici le scénario d'une prise
de la capitale ukrainienne Kiev est
envisagée c'est ce qui se profile ce
matin
c'est on n'a pas envie d'y croire on n'a
pas on n'a pas envie de croire que ce
serait possible maintenant c'est
difficile de prétendre le contraire en
tout cas ça c'est si l'aviation russe a
lancé des bombardements sur Kiev que
peut-on penser d'autres oui la Russie
Vladimir Poutine a décidé de prendre
Kiev de prendre la capitale ukrainienne
je je en vous disant cela je ne
comprends même pas comment on peut en
arriver à cette réalité mais c'est ce
qui semble ce profil effectivement qu'en
est-il de l'opinion publique en Russie
on le sait elle est cadenasser il est
très difficile de la mesurer on sait
pour l'heure que 137 ukrainiens ont été
tués plus de 300 blessés il y en a
encore des nouveaux ce matin au moins
trois blessés dans des tirs de missiles
russe en Ukraine à Kiev comment comment
réagit la population russe on le sait on
l'a vu hier plusieurs personnes ont
bravé les interdictions de manifester il
y a eu des arrestations
oui il y a eu des manifestations hier à
travers toute la Russie mais elles
étaient vraiment minimes à ce qu'on
attendrait de la part de la population
d'un pays qui dont le dirigeant a
attaqué le pays voisin il se trouve que
par exemple ce matin encore je regardais
le journal télévisé russe de la
télévision d'État de la chaîne info on
continue aussi à 24 que regarde la
plupart de la population russe et c'est
ils écrivent l'histoire à l'envers comme
depuis le début de ce conflit et les
gens entendent que l'Ukraine attaqué la
Russie que l'Occident mène une guerre de
propagande et des informations envers la
Russie pour la désaouais je disais que
Vladimir Poutine prétend ramener la paix
et la démocratie en Ukraine et rétablir
les droits de l'homme là où il y avait
une dictature donc les Russes ils
entendent cela et presque
automatiquement il le répète et
l'agressivité monte au fur et à mesure
que cette propagande s'intensifie
qu'elle désigne des ennemis l'Occident
l'Ukraine et les Russes commencent à se
barricader mentalement dans cette dans
cette dans cet état d'esprit de
forteresse assiégée il y a sans aucun
doute une brèche dans l'opinion est plus
on se rapproche de la ligne de front on
est ici à Belgorod plus cette brèche et
palpable puisque les gens sentent ils
entendent la guerre ils voient venir la
guerre vers eux ils ont peur et donc ils
ne veulent pas de la guerre alors que là
où j'étais à course qu'hier à 130 km
j'avais des gens qui me disaient
clairement oui on est pour la guerre on
doit ramener le bien par la force
Vladimir Poutine il a raison il ne fait
rien d'irraisonnable si il intervient
c'est parce que il faut venir à bout des
nazis ukrainien et cetera et cetera des
choses qu'on entend depuis 2014 depuis
le début de ce conflit cette histoire
parallèle cette histoire à l'envers qui
que Vladimir Poutine a écrit pour pour
sa population pour raconter en fait une
histoire qui n'est absolument pas celle
de la réalité et accusé au contraire les
autres de mentir
cette guerre elle a une visée
nationaliste on l'a compris mais
Vladimir Poutine en tout cas c'est c'est
notre impression ne se soucie pas ou peu
de son peuple et de son opinion est-ce
que ça peut se retourner contre lui
alors la visée nationaliste je n'y en
serai moi en disant viser impérialiste
parce que il s'agit de rétablir et
Vladimir Poutine l'a dit dans son
discours que moi j'appelle un manifeste
il s'agit pour lui de rétablir la Russie
dans ses frontières historiques qui sont
celles de l'Empire et qui aurait été
celle de l'URSS si un certain Lénine
n'avait pas fait la bêtise d'instaurer
des États indépendants au sein de
l'Union soviétique c'est ce qui lui a
reproché et Vladimir Poutine il a 7
ambition là donc on ne peut plus parler
de nationalisme parce que Vladimir
Poutine il accuse de nationalisme le
camp d'en face qui prétendrait à une
Ukraine indépendante à une Ukraine
souveraine et une Ukraine droit à ses
propres frontières il a dit c'est la
Russie qui a créé l'Ukraine l'Ukraine en
tant qu'État n'existe pas alors est-ce
que sa population peut lui en vouloir
pour ce discours et pour et pour cette
prise de position ou tout simplement
pour la guerre oui évidemment comme je
le disais il y a une brèche il y a une
peur surtout qui revient mais surtout il
faut voir que cette cette brèche et
cette peur et vous le disiez c'est
tentative de manifestation s'accompagne
aussi d'une pression qui va aller
crescendo et la réponse sera symétrique
des autorités pour tout velléité et
toute tentative de contester d'autant
plus en temps de guerre d'autant plus
lorsque Vladimir Poutine ce colosse au
pied d'argile et son pouvoir voudrais
consolider l'opinion autour de son
action qui qui vu l'ampleur de celle-ci
justement il va vouloir s'assurer le
soutien de la population et peu importe
qu'il m'aime pourvu qu'il me craignent
et bien il va amplifier la répression au
fur et à mesure pour s'assurer ce
soutien j'ajoute une dernière chose
c'est que il est à craindre que si
Vladimir Poutine envahit effectivement
l'Ukraine et c'est le scénario le plus
probable à l'heure actuelle il y aura
là-bas des purges des arrestations
toutes toutes opinion antirrus sera très
violemment réprimé et on sait à quel
point les Ukrainiens en ont gros sur le
cœur contre la Russie depuis le début de
cette guerre et je pense que le flot de
réfugiés qui va quitter l'Ukraine au fur
et à mesure ne quittera pas seulement
les combats et les bombardements mais
qui sera aussi et surtout l'instauration
de ce régime autoritaire qui est celui
de Vladimir Poutine dernière question
très rapidement Elena les sanctions
économiques à venir contre la Russie
pourrait-elle aussi pousser les Russes à
se rebeller malgré la répression à venir
alors la grève du portefeuille ou du
moins la rébellion du portefeuille
contre celle de l'opinion je pense que
les Russes effectivement s'il y a une
brèche quelque part c'est lorsqu'ils
sentent que la situation elle touche à
leur frigo elle touche à leur
portefeuille elle touche alors qu'elle
était de vie c'est là où la colère monte
on l'a vu avec les manifestations qui
ont des raisons sociales comme celle des
chauffeurs de poids lourds qui vont
augmenter leur taxe de transport ou des
choses comme ça qui paraissent très
marginal mais effectivement la colère
elle a moins de mal à s'exprimer sur des
questions très concrètes et très
sociales plutôt que sur les questions
politiques ou là le peuple russe a un
petit peu abandonné donc effectivement
au fur et à mesure que les sanctions
vont toucher l'économie que peut-être on
sera suspendu du système Swift que le
rouble est en train de s'effondrer que
le pays va se fermer enfin on peut
imaginer les pires scénarios on va pas
le faire pour le moment parce que dans
les jours qui viennent on va juste avoir
l'information et les faits sur ce qui va
se passer mais c'est vrai que là
effectivement c'est ou le bas blesse et
on verra quelle sera la réponse du
pouvoir russe face face à cette possible
débat que l'économique qui va toucher la
population russe maintenant il était
supposé que Vladimir Poutine a prévu ce
scénario il faut quand même pour
comprendre que 2014 depuis 2014 et
depuis que les sanctions sont en place
on s'y prépare on se tourne vers la
Chine on se tourne vers vers d'autres
solutions et la Russie je pense se
préparer depuis un moment à se rendre de
plus en plus indépendante du système
occidental pour son économie Elena
Volochine envoyé spécial de France 24 à
Belgorod en Russie merci infiniment à
vous Elena pour tous ces éléments